[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens alors je ne me prends
pas très souvent mais je dois dire que
c'est pas formidable il ya souvent des
retards des suppressions de trains
des coupures de lignes incroyable
bonjour je viens de me faire bizarre mon
sac
c'est incroyable ça à délinquants
juvéniles un sas et la délinquance
infantile devant ma soeur tattoo toi
incroyable messi fait car jacques est un
peu plus de cette violence donc c'est
très direct très rapide
et puis j'ai la chance aussi d'avoir une
voiture et une voiture que je peut garer
dans ma cour donc les autres
déplacements je les fais en voiture je
suis un très mauvais citoyens et votre
elle en pense quoi
j'ai pas de frères et trois soeurs je
pense qu'elles n'ont pas d'opinion sur
la question de quelqu'un d'un bureau
sans alors je me retourne puisqu'il
vient de me taper sur l'épaule
bah oui mais il me ressemble pas
beaucoup quand même
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens ben en fait ça
dépend lesquels parce que par exemple
moi je prends le rer b tous les matins
malgré ce qu'on dit ça va s'il ya trop
de monde
ça sent pas bon après les gens ils sont
pas respectueux et se bousculent
il trompe sedan et puis lé couloir quand
on marche ça tu as l'impression de te
taper tout paris à pied donc c'est le
votre est il en pense quoi ta qui
voulait que j'en pense moi c'est pas la
gauche à ce volet qu'on pense quoi ce jt
assad
on est en train de chercher les sept
boules de cristal nous en fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]